what happened
jailbreak led by Liza Warren either
someone enjoy watching them thank you
then I can't make a movie see you
breathing down my neck you're under
arrest for the murder of Detective
William Malone
hey everybody what's up so if you guys
didn't tell tonight's Green Arrow it was
all about gun control but is very in
keeping with classic Green Lantern Green
Arrow Denny O'Neil run so I'll explain
all the Easter eggs but careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen the episode
yet there's also some really cool
Suicide Squad arrow stuff happening
later than I'll explain at the end of
the video there are a couple things that
the Green Arrow character is really good
for if you go back to the classic Denny
O'Neil Neal Adams run it's really
politically charged it's mostly all
about drugs this episode was all about
gun violence so I'm sure half of you
really loved all the great speeches that
Oliver got as mayor queen that was one
of the things that the classic Green
Arrow did really well so they're
actually being very comic book II with
this and I'm sure there are a bunch of
other people that were really upset with
the way they treated the gun violence
issue so please try to keep it under
control in the comments but there is a
new round of the flash ring giveaway all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
be sure to click that Bell to enable
alerts so you don't miss anything but
overall really solid episode so let's do
top 10 WTF and comic book Easter eggs
but number 10 just to see it's coming
back to the station there's an all-out
assault someone opened fire on the
mayor's office everybody's ok with the
exception of the DA who gets sent to the
hospital with a gunshot wound very
important things happening in this
episode for his characters it will be
big later this season but they're kind
of spoilery because they're doing a
comic book arc for that character if you
didn't know the DA is a comic book
character he has an alternate persona
it's very big this season on arrow so as
they reveal things we'll talk about it
some people don't like it when I talk
about comic book stuff even if it sort
of highlights things that might be
happening later so C is back wild dog is
now Quentin full-time assistant I really
loved his character arc in this episode
the number 9 first of many wild dog
flashbacks we meet his wife he had a
child or has a child so we learned they
clawed their way out of the glades he's
hardcore against drugs in present day
and loves his guns the flashbacks tell
the story of why that is and how he
comes to that conclusion of why drugs
are so bad in why guns saved lives so I
feel like the writers did a pretty good
job of balancing the issue in the
episode like you have mister terrific
who's arguing with wild dogs they're
like the two
sides of the argument but there are
other people in the episodes that are
sort of split on it
number eight though gun of the different
kind Felicity's Pandora Drive is getting
them more useful information faster than
they normally would get it it's crazy
useful but the way they're highlighting
it makes it seem really sinister like
something really bad is going to happen
in the whole theme of the episode was
not trampling people's freedoms in order
to protect them like we don't want to
get rid of guns we want people to be
able to have guns but we also want to
protect their lives so Felicity was
basically invading all these people's
privacy to get the information on the
shooter so she herself is sort of doing
the things that everyone's getting hung
up about in the episode and that's going
to continue to be a big thing that sees
unless she's not going to stop doing
that anytime soon but it's crazy useful
and it gets the job done
number seven more backstory on Black
Canary she's really badass with the bo
staff we learned that she spent a lot of
time deep undercover we kind of learned
that when we first met the character -
she was a really good detective so she
just picked up skills wherever she
needed it so she's a really badass
fighter but in real life she's unable to
move forward she's like staying in their
temporary digs on this cot this very
Spartan lifestyle because she doesn't
know how to be normal again after going
through hell so she and Diggle has this
nice storyline in the episode where he
helped her realize that she needed to
give herself permission to be normal
again so it's okay to get the apartment
it's okay to move forward so that is
going to be a bigger thing later this
season and then I think even in season
six because we don't have a big presence
in the police station so we got to talk
about Black Canary in the police
department number six is Oliver
interrogating the Bertinelli crime
family it was so fun to go back to their
family everybody wants hunters back so
anytime they find a reason to go back to
them it's a lot of fun like hey Helena
Bertinelli is out there somewhere just
waiting to come back and kick some ass
waiting for that birds of prey episode
to happen this is where we loop it back
around to the vigilante haven't seen him
in a while but this is all about gun
violence in the vigilante is mr. guns if
wild dog loves guns vigilante wants to
marry guns but there's something really
big about his character in the comics we
can't really talk about it yet because
it's kind of spoilery but just follow
the district attorney's storyline his
wife the way they're trying to get rid
of
gun violence but also allow people the
freedom to carry weapons it's a
double-edged sword so I'll try to
explain later on my WTF list because
just regulating guns doesn't necessarily
get rid of gun violence the way they
explained in the episode which is
actually fairly accurate
so he made force with force and it sort
of tips the Hat for number 5 mayor
Oliver Queen needs to solve the problem
not the green arrow he can't punch his
way or shoot an arrow through this
problem Oliver starts questioning
everything he's done this is part of the
Prometheus art meeting everyone with
force just perpetuates the cycle of
violence is a problem as they visited
during the Christopher Nolan Batman
films like we put the cape and cowl on
it inspires other people to pick up guns
and get even crazier the bad guys to
match force with force wish they did a
really good job of calling back to at
the end of the episode with that wild
dog tag like he sees Oliver killed
damian darhk-- so it's true oliver
killing people does get rid of big
problems but it also leads to other big
problems happening which number four we
actually find play out with wild dogs
wife in the way that she dies so she has
a drug problem he is hardcore against it
but then when a drug dealer comes
calling to get his money it leads to her
dying indirectly because of gun violence
so during the fight he's able to kill
the drug dealer but accidentally as he's
falling a bullet goes off and kills his
wife I actually thought it was going to
kill his daughter too but I guess they
didn't want to be that pessimistic about
it so the daughter will totally come
back later this season they have to
bring her back after that setup but you
see what they're doing here guns saved
his family but also directly led to
their deaths
it's another way of showing that there's
no clear answer to the problem you can
get rid of drugs that might have saved
his family you could get rid of guns
that might have saved his family but
that's not going to end gun violence and
that's not going to end drug-related
violence either and the thing is is you
know number three that it compromises
they reach at the end of the episode is
actually a really nice end tack it just
shows you that wild dog guns aren't
going anywhere
Oliver is capable of being an effective
mayor which is actually really important
he wasn't so hot at being CEO but he's
actually being a pretty good mayor so
far and then they laid a little bomb
that's going to go off later when that
Councilwoman said I'm going to extract a
political price
from you which means that Oliver is
probably going to have to do something
that's going to paint him in a shady
light to repay all this debt the same
thing with the Bratva
the Brava super shady organization and
he is in their debt now so when they
come calling it's not going to be good
but number two is black canary joining
the police force this is going to be
very important like I said for season
six we need a presence in the police
department even if it's not going to be
Quentin anymore it's sort of like arrow
Law & Order
you have Oliver Queen working at the
government then you need somebody
working for law enforcement so they're
taking them down as vigilantes but
they're also able to use the resources
of the city to get justice the legal way
so that it sticks when they take people
down and they don't have to kill people
meaning that it's not super shady
anymore because that's what's coming
back to hot Oliver this season all the
bodies that he dropped in season one so
really my number one moment was all of
the Oliver speeches
towards the end of the episode when he
talked the shooter down which is a bit
of a comic book Easter Egg for a Batman
villain but hands down a couple of the
best speeches that I've ever heard come
out of Stephen Amell mouth home of the
brave you know great final speech
acknowledging both sides of the issue
and really are comes back to classic
green arrow now we just need to get that
Van Dyke you know maybe season six he
rolls up he has the beard when I think
of all the people that I've lost
I remember the choices that I was forced
to make in light of those tragedies
some choices were easy
but the important choices the choices
that were worth making they were hard
and hard choices require bravery
fortunately we live in the home of the
brave and we don't run from hard choices
we rise up and we face tomorrow together
but the real big thing you guys should
get excited for is sort of the Suicide
Squad stuff that's happening with next
week's episode is a bit of a hat tip to
that China white and Cupid or coming
back in a sort of prison break in the
actor that plays Diggle David Ramsey was
teasing that they could totally do
Suicide Squad stuff in the future
meaning that could even happen later
this season I'm not expecting it but I'm
really thinking season six stuff
bringing the Suicide Squad back on arrow
because they did it so well it was one
of the best things about the show during
season two in addition to the
Deathstroke arc I feel like their
stories work so well with the types of
stories the arrow does the crime drama
so I only get really excited when I hear
about Suicide Squad stuff happening on
arrow but I'm not expecting Deadshot
back anytime soon but if you heard it
there's actually a rumor now that Mel
Gibson might direct the Suicide Squad
sequel that'll be an interesting movie
it would be kind of weird because he
hasn't done a lot of comic book stuff
but all wait till they confirm stuff to
talk about that more I just think it's
an interesting idea Mel Gibson Suicide
Squad - but what's going to happen next
is is I'll post a black panther teaser
videos they teased a whole bunch of
stuff about what's going on in that
movie they're actually shooting it right
now and then I'll do my Legion video
episode - so if you haven't seen it yet
you still have time to watch the Legion
episode before I post that video later
today but congratulations to the latest
injustice giveaway winner Trani burst
you win a copy of the game please
private message being on the back end of
my channel it's injustice - so new black
pants that are coming in just a little
while thank you so much for watching
guys while you wait for that you can
click here for the Thor Ragnarok teaser
it's badass and you can click here for
another badass WTF x-23 origin scenes I
will see you guys in the next video
you